welcome to this video playing infernal
XM I forget the name of the sky pave
punk rock over 2,600 GM so let's see two
nights in place 95 I'm very much at this
line it's really just blundering a pawn
why do people play that where do we add
strange from such a good player okay
yeah here I have two more than one
possibility even a d6 as a move I am
sorry h6 as a move preventing 95 but
there should be seven is a very simple
equalizer that i'm going to play now now
c6 and t5s very ok for black pony I can
I can also try to refute what he did
with them there was some kind of things
that I am then I mentioned with with age
six and so I want I want a simple
position
maybe maybe this isn't very precise Oh
p8 okay can probably take Queen h5 with
the tempo and then it's turn the languid
can argue can argue with this probably I
could have played played that much
better Bishop g5 yeah let's just trade
this stuff
yeah of course I'm have the the bed
Bishop but it's nothing that should be a
to vary some here Queen to d2 that's
probably nonsense need to get get the
rook traded him and I want to prevent
age six prolly something something I
should do is g5 and move here g5 i can
put 25 queen f 6 h-6 not a good idea so
this means that King g7 probably wasn't
a super super great decision but it's
not it's not like I should can I go just
age six
I i think i can check a 74 hahaha yeah
okay this is how we can do stuff like
that just blundering pawns ok John day
upon check it's just the airport Queen
f6 Quincy seven
Jim
and I Bishop g6r come on well that's
frustrating yeah after this nonsense
opening okay yeah i'm just an
exaggerated like a total idiot around
here this is just a total draw I mean
absolutely nothing going on I just need
to be a little bit a little bit precise
IAM Bishop d7 first maybe of whatever
Queen d2 he has absolutely nothing here
just the rooks getting traded on the
e-file and then it's just said wrong and
what I played is really idiotic King g7
is really bad i mean why not just this
yeah he has to trade and here you can't
even argue that I'm quicker on the edge
file I have c5c for this is even better
for black his position as this always
annoys me very much if people play a
known nonsense line like castles this is
just a ? move yeah and very well known
since like the 19th century that it's no
leading nowhere and I can even play
night d6 all night f6 all it's okay for
black here h6 is the best move but I
didn't want to get into this this crazy
stuff after Queen d5 and this is just as
mentioned totally nothing check then
played it like a total [ __ ] ready yeah
Queen g5 is just wrong I overlooked
green f form this was a strong move
Queen a form this makes things really a
bit tricky now I cannot do something
like that now and he somehow threatens
to play age six so I went with this and
this just blenders the porn yeah and now
I'm worse and probably almost losing
it's also a bad structure of course I
mean age six is a move that
you really don't like to play I was just
thinking that I don't lose material
still is probably still not much going
on if the comp is just giving FCS f6
equal or king j equal but I've given
some ground so just this is good you
must take yeah try to trade everything
off for draw simply it's simply nothing
nothing happening here yeah but I have
this always annoying but simply simply
bad play by me okay thanks for watching